los trabajadores pretendían llegar a la
sede del ministerio público para
entregar el documento sin embargo le fue
impedido el paso por una barricada de la
Policía Nacional bolivariana desde el
interior del país también partieron
varias movilizaciones que exigen el día
de hoy salarios dignos un sueldo
promedio de seis a diez dólares
mensuales que no les alcanza para cubrir
ni siquiera las necesidades básicas
consultamos algunas de sus impresiones
para el gobierno de Nicolás maduro los
trabajadores no valemos hoy a pesar que
le habíamos informado que llegábamos
hasta la fiscalía general de la
república Le tuvo miedo porque maduro le
tiene miedo al pueblo en la calle y yo
creo que si un gobierno le tiene miedo a
su pueblo ya no merece ser gobierno esto
es un llamado a la Corte Penal
Internacional que sigue el caso a
Venezuela el derecho a un salario digno
también es un derecho humano fundamental
para poder acceder alimento a salud ha
vestido al calzado tengo 14 años
trabajando en el hospital general de
ocumare bertuy y lo que cobro son
cuatro dólares No llego ni siquiera
cinco dólares eso no me alcanza ni
siquiera para comprarme mi medicamento
no me alcanza para los pasajes no me
alcanza absolutamente para nada señor
presidente tengo una condición de salud
y no cuento ni siquiera con mi hospital
que cubra mi necesidades de salud
mientras el gobierno juega el desgaste
nosotros nos mantenemos en la calle por
nuestra dignidad por un salario digno
pero en caso de no tener respuesta
porque ya tenemos diez años en esto los
trabajadores ya tenemos 10 años los
trabajadores no vamos a organizar para
el cambio político a este país desde el
mes de enero los trabajadores públicos
están a la espera del anuncio un momento
salarial que a la fecha no sea
materializado sin embargo El Ejecutivo
ya ha advertido que no es posible
equiparar el salario a la canasta básica
pues no cuentan con el presupuesto según
estimaciones de la Universidad Católica
Andrés Bello al cierre de este año el
índice inflacionario en Venezuela podría
superar el 400 por ciento